in 13a we simply looked at this idea of
a scatter plot someone remind me it's
even there on the board if you want to
look when do you use a scatter plot in
what situation when you've got two
variables you want to try and work out
are then related in some way closely or
otherwise okay so these are some of the
scatter plots that you saw now one of
the things about this is that sometimes
you know your what data is patchy in
these cases you've got a lot of data
okay but say we actually had on a door
like this say we actually had some data
missing but being a gap in our dollars
don't even looked a bit like this okay
now this is not that unusual this is not
that unusual because there's lots of
different sources of data and sometimes
you don't have everything all nice and
neat as if it lines up perfectly so when
you have gaps in your data what do you
do I'm going to introduce this idea of
the line of best fit maybe you have
heard of before it's a very common idea
but if you have data where one variable
interrelated to another then it should
roughly form a line it should sit on a
line so we're going to talk about half
of the technical way of doing this a bit
later on but right now all you need to
do is an approximate literally line let
go and make a bit bigger our line goes
straight through you're done so being
that the relationships that we're
looking for here are linear your line of
their sphere is going to be a straight
line
okay now this exercise you're about to
do is really just about this is a very
wrong idea okay drawing that through and
using that now
to then predict okay what if I know is
some person and I know they're
measurement on this axis I can use this
line of best fit to make a reasonable
guess as to what they will be on this
axis doesn't necessarily have to be
exactly accurate but I'm just trying to
get a ballpark right I will be able to
predict things and that's really really
useful later on is
two exercises time we're actually going
to look at there's an actual technical
way of elavil spreadsheets and
what-have-you of constructing this line
okay
because at the web it like this could be
a lighter best fit but I could just as
easily draw you know roughly speaking
that is your line of best fit or you
know I could always draw anywhere I like
if I don't have some kind of agreed-upon
measure for how to say which is the line
of biscuit so line of best fit is what
I'm going to call it this frequently
because I think that was descriptive are
you also called it here it called a
trend line that's another company is a
bunch of different names for the same
idea it's a line that roughly passes
through the center of all of your diet
okay